the un's refugee agency says that donors
have not been fast enough in responding
to the emergency in Sudan the unhcr
statement comes as Sudan's warring site
signs an agreement to protect civilians
and the movement of humanitarian Aid it
follows several days of talks in Saudi
Arabia between the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces many
civilians have been trapped by nearly a
month of fighting Heba Morgan has more
from umdurman
the agreement is just a confirmation
from the two sides that they will abide
by the international loan when it comes
to conflicts which is allowing for a
safe passage for civilians who are
caught up in the conflict to be able to
leave the areas where there is active
fighting to a safer place and as well as
allowing Aid organizations and the
organization's concerned to check on
welfare of prisoners of wars or those
who've been arrested by either warring
parties it also allows for the
withdrawal from vital facilities
facilities like water plants power
plants and the refinery which supplies a
majority of the country now that's the
agreement that was signed but it's not
what people had hoped for what they
wanted was even if temporary a true a
ceasefire a truce that would end the
fighting even for a little bit for
civilians to be able to leave their
homes and be able to access facilities
like Banks be able to go to the market
to buy what they need to store what they
need and for those who can because a lot
of them cannot for those who can't to be
able to leave the capital so many people
here say that this falls short of what
they want and that this agreement even
though it's the basic when it comes to
what they need they say they do not
believe would actually hold
fighting is intensifying in the town of
that's near the border of Sudan and Chad
zambas Ravi reports from the nearby town
of Audrey in eastern chant
we're here in the town of Audrey in Chad
across from the border with Sudan not
far away just about a 30 or 40 minute
drive is the Sudanese town in the west
Darfur region the town of al-jinena now
for days we've been hearing about an
uptick in violence there and overnight
we heard loud explosions intermittent
explosions as well as what sounded like
heavy machine gun fire coming from the
suddenly side of the border now it is
impossible to know exactly what is
happening on that side of the border at
the moment but what we are hearing for
sure what we do know for sure is that
there is ongoing fighting in westar4
what is it what exactly is happening
reports suggest that it is the Sudanese
military trying to repel approaching
armed groups that are approaching their
base that are approaching the town of
elginina that are approaching Villages
around algenena and carrying out attacks
now exactly who's behind these attacks
is also something that remains unclear
the villagers the the residents of Sudan
Sudanese refugees fleeing into Chad have
harrowing accounts of what is going on
they blame African Arab fighters
fighters they say are the rsf fighters
they say are the genjiweed for looting
pillaging and burning their Villages and
for indiscriminate killing now the Chad
government the Chad military here on the
border is carefully patrolling those
border areas they say they are trying to
make sure that the fighting is contained
to Sudan but the humanitarian corridors
remain open and those people continue to
flee onto Chad's side of the Border in
search of safety the UN Chad's
government as well as the military
intelligence here in Audrey tell us that
over the last few days they've seen an
influx of between 20 and 25
000 people just from the instability
over the last few days effectively
doubling the overall number of refugees
nearly doubling that overall number
since the conflict in Sudan began around
four weeks ago now what they are telling
us is that doubling is going to create
an enormous strain on resource is the
U.N has requested for emergency funding
to cope with the crisis and the initial
estimates of nearly a hundred thousand
refugees fleeing from Sudan into Chad
that is becoming a ground reality here
now and fighting in elginina seems to be
getting worse
after Decades of conflict in their
Homeland more than 800 000 South
Sudanese fled to Sudan thousands of them
are now returning home leading to a
major humanitarian and logistical crisis
hermitasa reports from Juba
eight agencies are bringing in more
staff and whatever resources they have
to help thousands of people fleeing the
conflict in Sudan the humanitarian needs
are overwhelming people arrive every day
thousands are living in transit camps
most are South Sudanese waiting to move
away from the border as quickly as
possible is a logistical challenge I was
working the European migrant and Refugee
crisis in 2015.
and it took us weeks to set up a
logistical system to help people move
across the borders and to the
destinations that they wanted
and South Sudan is a lot more
complicated when it comes to
accessibility roads enormous distances
eight agencies are appealing for an
additional 96 million dollars to assist
people arriving here the government is
evacuating some refugees and returnees
but with few planes and resources it's
not enough Sudan and results Whirlwind
country until 2011 people in the South
vote overwhelmingly for South Sudan to
become an independent state but the two
still have strong economic and
diplomatic ties and what happens across
the border will affect what happens here
that's why South Sudan is leading
mediation efforts as part of the
regional block egad to get Sudan's
warning sides to stop fighting that's
why the government has decided to keep
our embassy open in Kato we are not
going to vacate like the rest
we believe we are also Sudanese like
them and if they are in trouble we need
to be on the spot so that this
communication can be encouraged the U.N
Refugee agency expects 240 000 people to
flee to South Sudan a few weeks ago many
of these families had relatively
ordinary lives now they find themselves
with little or Nothing at All
Jazeera Juba